and it's on these two cuz I don't really
wait why did you say it then begin
grease flow ensuring leakage is minimal
uh-huh turn main valve and confirm
primary flow right okay so this is four
or five I'm not sure about so let's just
take a chance on these two
so it's 50/50 now it's actually probably
less because I did it all right and then
do it right
stood one more freakin time or I'll pee
my pants for no apparent reason right
and then this one first
oh it doesn't seem like the order does
anything that whatever try now I will be
pissed if this doesn't work doesn't work
oh my god
freaking how am I supposed to know the
pressure is [ __ ] right
can I look somewhere I thought I saw I
could look somewhere could be hydraulics
at any rate some sort of fluid control a
symbol for water a symbol I'm definitely
lost on this one yeah me too so this is
water and that's what and that's
but I should be able yeah I've worked
that out wow they're really diffuse
it's kind of tricky actually ensure to
the other Baba connecting confirm
secondary flow how do I connect turning
around appropriate valve turn on cooling
system okay so these two gotta be
cooling system and then oh well it's
gotta be this one actually come on dude
I don't even know why I'm doing this I
have to open the gate shake now on that
it seems to be working
finally I took that took me a [ __ ]
long time but I did it that was corny
all right whatever
um I a slam sand stuff yeah no spooky
[ __ ] demon dogs here if they come I'm
[ __ ] ready they better bring it huh
yeah yeah whip whip whip whip whip hello
mammy that's weird
all right uh where's the game ah no no
no
hey no problem no problem good day good
day can you hear me yes well I hope that
your ears are working better than your
tongue so that you might hear huh [ __ ]
yard oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] there's a frickin
ugly
beginning in middle of the tunnel but
some things remain shrouded in darkness
yeah I know Lauren C message I hope this
helps but what you mean it didn't L wall
hole to the right of the fence go now
there is no time to wait where should I
go
wall right in fact time is one of the
few things we have in abundance Talia
what surprises are spoiled by such candy
curiosity and shock the down a note
that's not a note beyond the fence to
the right there should be a hole or
perhaps an access point to reach further
into the mind oh [ __ ] oh I got beef jerk
I got frickin beef jerk oh how do I open
though what's the access code he didn't
tell me the freaking access code hope
it's the same as before
wait it was click 'add he didn't tell me
the freaking access code she barely
knows don't tell me the Morse code is in
- one for AIDS
come on you kidding me
don't tell me the [ __ ] Morse code is
the I swear the penis yes
I'll swear the penis yeah it's very
conveniently close though now it's not a
conveniently close I'm just stupid where
the [ __ ] is it running around there too
[ __ ] long you didn't tell me the
frickin Morse code
ah okay can you guys type this down for
me this can't be right
my god all right
five
seven
- no oh [ __ ] I think the first one is
five in that yeah and then yeah three
five seven three
dude dude it was it three again five
seven three three
this isn't long one time
the the okay five seven three eight five
seven three eight five seven three eight
it's better be [ __ ] right when I
swear to God and my penis
I wonder what's worst whatever uh yeah I
still don't frickin remember I don't
five seven three eight five seven did I
say that yeah I did say that
five seven three hey yeah oh I forgot
about the doggy
[ __ ] you run while it's on eco peace
peace
[ __ ] beef turkey pick the [ __ ] beef
jerky
[ __ ] you lucky [ __ ] you got the right
golden African right oh my god we got a
wheel it's not [ __ ] up
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] this game see it's see you next
time god damn it
all right I am [ __ ] back I might some
oh [ __ ] ah my memory is like something
with a great many small holes we shall
be needing to perform some minor
demolition work so else we might one day
meet again for this desk we shall
require the use of a large earth eating
metal monster and that much huh thirsty
for juice from the place where things
are kept I'm sorry what by the way you
can call me red so brain name you
understand but but I am sure your Shri
doesn't name rather similar to a
cardigan clenching with water correctly
I know who he is he's the guy on the
picture I hear doggie [ __ ] that all
right so whoever [ __ ] said that the
frickin you throw beef jerky to distract
them it's a [ __ ] idiot and I hate you
it's just a broom this time [ __ ] this
[ __ ] up
oh [ __ ] he's thirsty for freaking blood
[ __ ] you
let's not stare at them I think they'll
find me if I stare at them I don't know
how I'm gonna get through though what
the [ __ ] yeah it's still there
what the [ __ ] okay it's gone let's no
it's not gum no let's go here
okay Ron
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay
yeah here
how am I supposed to know where the [ __ ]
were supposed to go beyond the fence all
right there should be a hole perhaps I
can access bla bla bla [ __ ] you
okay going to the freakin rides nope
toolshed
alright
hey yeah
oh I need a shill a [ __ ] seventh bleh
blender scares me
oh no I thought I want to what the [ __ ]
just happened
I thought I thought it was like a
pickaxe er no I mean uh whatever no all
right let's read this some of me wanted
me to not straight it some of you wanted
me to read it I guess I'm going to read
it see no report 66b bla bla bla bla bla
leader unlike the other finding 66b
appears to be manufactured there are
there the natural origin and so we're in
traditional interest and I need need I
say security
I had no idea what the [ __ ] I just read
the bulk of substance 63 was discovered
only six yards from where artifact
alright I think I get thoughts is going
artifact admits low level of light for
from seemingly inexhaustible energy
supply all right of course the Bravo la
approve [ __ ] blah blah okay I read all
the notes in amnesia and I'm glad I did
but I don't really feel like reading
notes
and there
and yeah about the camera thing it was
too dark you can you can't oh [ __ ] you
can't even see me like it's completely
pointless and I'm trying to fix it in
all kids sorts of freaking ways oh [ __ ]
I hate the [ __ ] dollies but it just
it just won't work
alright so we are that's where we came
from right and then now there we are
storage yeah that's all these good news
all right story [ __ ] is then I off the
down the note I had to see what he said
our holes in my mind are increasingly
gaping in your sanction where I had that
before life of storing it the entryway
is blocked so I wanted to squashing
material between my ears to squash you
the most squash it may not be perfect
like a hanging picture but my border
wise and backed up by time a POC a POC
improve your brain cells
I think he's insane hi as I may you must
think that I deceive you with by
admitting leagues on runways as far as
my eye is seen our rocky great extent
and yet you pass the way I out like it
what a puppy
freshly roll the tongue faces I hope
that you're one so sure it's better
company than I because now it is all you
have left
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
everywhere
okay I've a lot learning oh dude I'm
sorry sometimes my body hear the
whispers uncontrollable all spiders but
I think we are both sorrier than we are
safe a tunnel lies between a nearby
watery cave and the place was shorter
kiss inspection liner lying right from
the closed door and he will
what you seek
what there is a draft coming from the
in fact
where the [ __ ] did that come from
I
alright so the [ __ ] am I supposed to do
with this rocket sells looks I've given
up on life blah blah blah
this box should be ancient that's the
rest of the line but it looks better in
better Knick the side facing that
excavation seems more corroded inside a
clue
can't be more than some work
creepy station got a freaking pain my
creepy station
you